emma greed is probably best described as
the kardashian family's favorite
business partner she's played a crucial
behind-the-scenes role in helping them
transition from reality television into
the business world and she's helped them
start three companies including kim
kardashian shapewear brand skims and
good american the denim company that she
started with khloe kardashian reed grew
up as one of four daughters to a single
mother in east london and as she
describes it she was always extremely
interested in fashion and she would save
her money from odd jobs like doing a
paper round to buy fashion magazines
when she was in her early 20s she got
into the london school of fashion but
she couldn't afford to complete her
education there so she got a job at a
fashion show production company and
while working at the fashion show
production company she came up with the
idea for her first business independent
talent brand which connected fashion
designers with funding
you know it's so interesting because
being in fashion what i was seeing is
that i just learned so much more doing
these work experience placements than i
was getting from the college experience
and you know it was just one of those
things where i made that decision and i
look back on it you know i think that
there are reasons to stay in college of
course having that security of an
education but for me i just felt like
you know what i just need to hit the
ground and get in and meet people and
network while working in the fashion
industry emma kind of realized that
there was a need for a diverse
both in terms of size and racially
diverse fashion company because she felt
like a lot of companies were trying to
do it but it was more for show that it
was genuine so she came up with the idea
for good american and she had gotten to
know kris jenner from just being part of
the fashion show scene and chris said
that she should take it to chloe and
together they found a good american in
2016. and they claimed that when they
launched they had the most successful
denim launch in history they've expanded
into different categories like swimwear
and shoes and the company has just been
growing and very successful what we do
is work in this incredible size range so
we're creating clothing for all women
all the time from a size double zero to
a plus size 30 and there's nobody else
out there actually doing that and also
this important part about really never
sacrificing fashion for the sake of
inclusivity we're making clothes that
women really want to wear that they
can't get elsewhere and that's what's so
great about that business we're actually
serving a really underserved market
emma was approached by kim kardashian
about skims in 2019 and because she had
just created good american with chloe
and it felt like a natural fit for her
to join skims and she currently works as
the chief product officer her husband
jens greedy is the ceo of the company
and so together they kind of manage the
day-to-day operations as well as the
design and merchandising for the company
she's also the chairwoman of the 15
pledge and that was founded after the
murder of george floyd in may 2020. it's
a commitment from retailers like sephora
to pledge at least 15 of their shelf
space to black owned businesses and
entrepreneurs
what's so incredible about the pledge is
that we've created 10 billion dollars of
opportunity for black owned businesses
with the likes of nordstrom sephora
alter bloomingdale's all having taken
the pledge and it's meaning that so many
more entrepreneurs are getting access to
wholesale to retailers that they may
have otherwise been overlooked and so i
just think that you know for me
we talk so much about d e and i in our
businesses about you know diversity
about inclusion and you know it's time
that businesses put their money where
their mouth is if you actually want to
make a difference there are so many
great businesses out there that we can
interact with and that should be on the
shelves
and she also was a guest judge on shark
tank so if you're not in the fashion
industry you may recognize her from
there
one thing i think is important to
highlight about the story of emma is
that
you know a lot of celebrities launch
businesses and most of them are not
successful because it takes more than
just you know a whole bunch of instagram
followers to be successful so emma seems
to have found this perfect recipe of
collaborating
with these influencers but also
they have a business partnership where
they're both bringing equal amounts of
work and commitment to the table and
that's why these businesses seem to be
working
[Music]
you